the jurgen experience you got
double water bottles one water one
protein shake
you're not [ __ ] around no i knew you
know last time i wasn't aware how long i
would be here
now i'm prepared i'm gonna settle in i'm
not gonna be hungry my wife got me all
set up
water protein shake make sure that your
blood sugar doesn't drop
maintain energy levels you are uh a man
who has done one of the most difficult
things a person could do
you lost a ton of weight yeah and then
maintain keep
yeah right that's the hard part yeah
yeah the momentum of losing the weight
is good but most people they get to a
point and they want to take a break
and then once they take a break then it
all slides yeah it's a bit of both
sometimes i want to take a break but
then i want to get to that next level
so then get back on it well we're
talking about gucci mane before
we start a podcast gucci is the guy
who's done that yes he's maintained and
looks [ __ ] amazing
he was a big fella yeah at one point in
time when he had burr
tattooed on his face you know the ice
cream cone yeah yeah
and now he's shredded yeah he got rid of
that ice cream
[Laughter]
well you were saying it was the lean
right yeah yeah for sure
yeah codeine will play a lot that is
crazy
well he wasn't too fat in the other one
yeah actually that's like yeah that's
kind of like him mid losing weight in
that one you can find some real chunky
picture
yeah of him yeah he got thick
yeah and now he's shredded yeah
my inspiration yeah i mean my wife all
the time we look at him and his wife the
pictures they take what they do
and i'm like i wanna head in that
direction what do you do for working out
i have my trainer about three days a
week um sometimes two days a week and
then on top of that and we'll do you
know just
different circuits back chest you know
whatever whatever
legs and then um and then the other days
i'm always just trying to make sure i
hit the treadmill
twice a day for two miles on it twice a
day yeah
really you do it twice a day yeah in the
morning and night i don't do much
otherwise so you know all especially now
a lot of my stuff is
sitting in front of a computer
podcasting and playing games on twitch
and stuff like that so
i feel like oh i'm going to spend that
long i gotta
start the day treadmill in the day
treadmill that's discipline
i like that it is i [ __ ] hate it so
it definitely is discipline but you like
the results
yeah i like how i feel like the
compliments you know i was just doing
this thing the other day and um
uh jake johnson the guy from new girl
i'm in a cartoon with him and like
that's like you know he's like a leading
man dream body guy and he's looking at
me he's like man
he's like you're looking [ __ ] good
man you got your [ __ ] together you look
like you're about to lead your own
show and i hear [ __ ] like that and i'm
like okay yeah i better
get on that treadmill again yeah yeah
that helps right
it really does yeah the positive
feedback and positive energy
that's one thing that i like about what
you do you are very positive
like you're you're very warm and
friendly like all the [ __ ] that you do
online
you're all smiley and positive and
friendly it's cool it's it's got it
gives off a good vibe like when i
look at your instagram posts or read
something that you post it's like
ron is on the good path yeah i try to
you know because it's just
it's so easy to go the other way and get
caught up in what
other people are doing and what you
think you should be doing
which i battle all of that too so i
don't ever try to act like oh i'm just
like oh everything's great it's like of
course i go through [ __ ] all the time
but like
i think i choose to support my friends i
choose to support
positive things because that's what i
can control and that's to me
fighting against that negative as as
opposed to like just joining everybody
in the fray yeah what do you mean by
like
how do you feel like when you say like
you feel that too like the field you
feel
the draw to the negative oh i mean
because we all like you know we just
want things you know so i wanted a
netflix special i want to be a lead in a
show i want my own show
you know and i've already do a lot of
great things but
and that's why i have to balance it out
because i'm like oh man i'm in such a
great position i do
so many wonderful things i what always
helps me actually is talking to people
like you or talking to people like bert
talking to any comedian that's been
doing it
like 20 years plus when i'm at like 14
now
and when i talk to them and then they
are like oh hold on slow the [ __ ] down
man
like you look at where you are and what
you're doing for how long you've been
doing it you're [ __ ]
aces man so chill the [ __ ] out and play
it out
don't freak out and that always you know
having faith that always helps me